il se dirigeait tout droit vers les
prolongations mais à 20 secondes de la
fin les élans courtois ont encaissé le
but de la défaite fausse qu importe si
but à 5 on a fait un match globalement
pas trop mauvais on est mené au score
quasiment tout le match et voilà sur la
fin on sait faire c'est un peu
démobilisée c'est ce qui nous a fait
perdre sur les versements sincèrement je
pense que le match était pour nous mais
voilà on s'est démobilisé sait et on va
dire les enjeux de certains matchs quoi
les chocs avait même deux buts d'avancé
cinq minutes avant la fin de la partie
grâce à plusieurs contre attaques ils
ont réussi à mettre la main sur le match
desfossés revenu à chaque fois notamment
lorsqu'ils étaient en supériorité
numérique à cause des multiples fautes
élan courtoise donc nos faiblesses c'est
on s'énerve trop vite et on s'énerve
beaucoup trop vite et du coup c'est vrai
que ça a tendance à sortir les joueurs
un peu du match aller les objectifs ça
va être de se remettre à flot de revenir
intégrer petit à petit le haut du
tableau en espérant aller chercher une
place en quarts de finale mais rien de
facile pour moi on va essayer de se
préparer un peu mieux là pour le
prochain match début janvier et s'il a
travaillé est-ce qui a travaillé c'est
vraiment la concentration je pense et
aussi l'application dans le but
les chocs d'elancourt son cinquième du
classement sur 8 équipes prochain match
le 7 janvier face à un adversaire direct
au classement paris xiii